[Música]
então eu hoje Comprei 15 produtos
obviamente que eu sei que não é Campo
que as coisas já chegaram é tipo antes
então se quiserem baixar a aplicação
pessoal tá aí no meu primeiro link só
clicar nesse link aí é só baixar em
aplicação que vocês vão ganhar um
desconto de 50% na vossa primeira compra
então utilizem aproveitem agora Malta
Esse é o meu link de afiliado Portanto
vocês ajudam também a usar o meu link
Então tá aí primeiro link da descrição
Bora primeiro o produto isto aqui
parece-me ser um selador de de produtos
tipo batata frita e coisas assim sabes
de plástico Olha aí aqui diz se ela
Adorador tipo isto é uma resistência oh
que bonito gosto desta cor Rosinha
Rosinha bom isto serve para fechar a
embalagens de plástico olha até posso
utilizar aqui com uma embalagem Bora lá
estar o produto aqui deve precisar de
pilha né claro não há nada de bordo se
não resultar pensa eu acho que é só
apertar e isto vai fechar a embalagem
Bora três dois um vai
Uh tá a funcionar
não acredito
Ah eu apertei pouco
precisa apertar bem precisa apertar bem
Malta
OK Agora aprendi mais e cortei o
plástico mas funciona Malta
este produto recomendo até recomendo
próximo produto que na verdade são dois
eu comprei aqui também um conjunto de
plásticos isto aqui serve para fazer
pixel art eu tenho certeza que vocês já
devem ter visto essas Pixel Arts à venda
ou imagens no Pinterest e tudo mais
então eu comprei um balde com esses
Plásticos e comprei também esta base
Porque é necessário para nós construímos
aqui a nossa imagem eu não vou construir
aqui porque eu ainda tenho que decidir o
desenho que eu vou fazer mas em
princípio eu vou fazer já uns Pokémons o
gengar Ah talvez façam Super Mario a
planta do Mário também aqui está o
plástico Esta é a base onde nós fazemos
a PicsArt tem aqui os buraquinhos todos
Uh que linda muitas coisas e com isto eu
consigo fazer imagens em pixel art e
colocar um imã por trás por exemplo e
usar numa frigorífico ou em qualquer
outro tipo de decoração em casa é muito
louco Malta já deixem aí em baixo para
fazermos uma explicação Artes aqui para
o canal posso fazer um vídeo exclusivo
só fazer a explicação de likes a ensinar
a fazer também em casa mas esta ca
ixinha de plástico tem que ser bem
prática porque já vem com muitas cores é
só escolher eventualmente se acabar a
volta a comprar um baú deste e Okay
vocês achavam com o fidget Spinner tinha
acabado em 2017 aqui está o novo fidget
Spinner 23 Isto é incrível porque eu voa
eu fingir estou a fazer um unboxing
porque eu já testei e isto realmente
funciona Malta Inclusive tem pelos o que
aqui
é por isso que isto não me deixa mentir
né porque pelo uso aqui neste
dispositivo eletrónico é um bocado
estranho vir de fábrica né Como podem
ver ele tem uma ventoinha aqui tem aqui
um mecanismo também que serve como peão
porque se ele cair fica a rodar Bora
testar
aí uma opinião ele gira como um Beyblade
tranquilaço
mas se eu virar ao contrário Olha aí
mas eu vou
Ai meu Deus
está ele funcionar mais uma vez não
posso esquecer que tem que ser assim
espera aí
ele levou a bumeran Portanto vocês podem
tirar para a frente e ele volta para
trás incrível
mano muito bom
isto realmente funciona é um ótimo
brinquedo próximo produto ontem em cima
da cozinha neste caso é um cortador de
pizza em forma de Machado Espero que
tenha uma boa qualidade
Bora próximo Malta eu comprei aqui estes
fones porque pareciam ser ideais para
fazer exercício físico eu tenho usado os
airpodes da Apple uma coisa que eu
reparei que eles se saltam muito o
ouvido enquanto eu estou a fazer o meu
cardio então eu preferi comprar uns 10
que agarram bem a cabeça Ok para nunca
me saltar e realmente eles funcionam
porque eu já os testei Ok mas vamos aqui
abrir porque estamos em vídeo e tudo
mais são uns fones da Lenovo agora eu só
não sei se são verdadeiros são meio que
aqueles verdadeiros diferentes sabem mas
em princípio é do novo mesmo
simplesmente vem com tudo a encher Olha
aí eu tenho que Plus ó vem assim todos
dobrados Man isto costuma já nem me
lembro bem mas acho que foram uns 12 €
está aqui o preço eu vou-vos mostrar
baratíssimos aqui tem mais tem metal até
pensei que fossem todos de plástico
devido ao preço mas até tem metal aqui
são fáceis de limpar tem aqui um botão
para ligar os fones eles acendem dá aqui
um ledzinho azul são Bluetooth ok que
vem aqui com um cabo pai para você para
carregamento Ok tem quantos cabo de Jeca
para ligar onde quiserem Se bem que isto
é um pouco inútil vocês vão usar o
Bluetooth dele para ligar o vosso
telemóvel o vosso smartphone o som não é
assim grande coisa mas pelo preço vale
super apenas Se quiserem uns fones só
para fazer exercício Isto é o ideal Man
custo-benefício incrível bons fones
portanto estou super contente com a Timo
e maltinha eu não estou a ser paga
atenção não estou a ser pago isto não é
patrocinado eu estou aqui a dar a minha
opinião sincera em relação aos produtos
este fones aqui da Lenovo valem mesmo a
pena okay eu não sei quanto é que tá
agora porque os preços estão sempre a
variar de vez em quando eles têm uma
promoção outras vezes eles não têm essa
promoção mas se vocês usarem o meu link
aí embaixo para sacar a aplicação e
usarem o meu código penso eu que vão ter
50% de desconto eu não sei até quando Ah
e quando é que vocês vão ver este vídeo
mas eu não sei até quando é que vocês
vão ter essa promoção então sejam
rápidos aproveitem os fãs ainda ficam
mais baratos mais um produtozinho gamer
desta vez é Gamer temos aqui uma barra
LED com cores que reagem ao som ó vem
aqui com a barra vem com um suporte Ok
já tá aqui todo arrebentado porque eu já
eu abri claro vem com um cabo a barra é
totalmente preta e depois veio colocar
branco não faz muito sentido devia ser
um bocado preto também eh mas ya vamos
dar desconto aqui vem o cabo de
carregamento Vem esta base que é muito
louca a entrada USB está aí PC isto
depois vocês ligam a uma porta USB no
vosso PC ou no vosso ecrã ou a uma Power
Bank até vou testar com uma Power Ban
Opa aí olha aí tá a funcionar
perfeitamente e ele reage com a voz
Malta Isto é incrível reparem ah ah ah
lá lá lá lá lá lá
vocês têm aqui três botões tem um monte
de Speed tem o Color bright e o Power Ok
vocês podem usar isto em cima do monitor
Assim fica muito louco podem usar assim
também ao lado é muito bacana se vocês
comprarem tipo umas três ou quatro
destas aqui Vale super a pena porque
infelita bastante bem o vosso setup fica
incrível e é só ligarem é um cabo USB é
super simples
da moda Malta é aqueles óculos do funk
daqueles óculos para vocês irem aos
festivais de música Olha aí estilo
Matrix mano eu tenho a certeza que estes
óculos foram menos de 2 €, mano tá aí o
preço tá sempre aí a passar o preço fica
excelente Olha aí
não há muita dizer acerca destes óculos
são plástico
bem resistente até estilosos é o que
interessa Bora próximo conteúdo este
produto é para o meu cãozinho um suporte
para saquetas do Cocó aí vem com as
sequetas do
embalagem para quem tem animais de
estimação vocês sabem que isto aqui é um
salva-vidas mesmo os são saco por aqui
apertam isto aqui à vossa cintura Pronto
Olha fica assim
ah posso levar à vontade
Easy próximos três produtos relativos à
Apple eu comprei aqui duas braceletes
para o relógio da Apple e comprei também
um protetor de ecrã porque eu estou
sempre a bater com o relógio em todo
lado e não quero estragá-lo
comprei também uma preta nota-se que é
um pouco mais fraco Ok nota-se cada
Apple claro que cada Apple é muito mais
rígida esta aqui tem um aspecto assim
mais frágil no entanto o material É o
mesmo é uma borrachinha um silicone Ok
Ok eu comprei na verdade este preta
também para combinar com este produto
aqui que é uma caixinha de proteção é
bonita vem aqui com uma estrelinhas de
limpeza bem vamos lá montar então aqui o
relógio sei lá encaixar uh ok fica com
esta borda preta à volta da funciona
perfeitamente Nice agora só para
combinar eu vou já testar aqui esta
bracelete preta mano isto já dá o outro
lado ao relógio Olha aí está um relógio
completamente diferente agora ele perde
a estética do relógio da Apple portanto
eu não sei se aqui está parecer um
relógio no Android sabe tá assim meio
estranho mas vamos lá usar a outra
Seleta agora muito melhor agora olha aí
fica incrível cinco estrelas Man cinco
estrelas só não curti Foi mesmo da capa
esquece próximo produto que na verdade
são dois comprei um medidor de
temperatura e humildade porque é Malta
porque agora vais ficar um inverno eu
sei que ainda estamos no verão mas no
inverno é que esta zona fica com muita
umidade Então eu tenho que ligar sempre
produzidador para não deixar uma idade
em casa e este aparelho aqui vai-me
ajudar também a perceber quanto a
umidade é que eu tenho nas minhas
divisões da casa o bem comprida Okay
está a funcionar já temperatura
24.2 aqui diz 24 okay e a humidade está
79%. Ou seja eu tenho muito humidade
aqui no estudo ah a humidade ideal o
nível de percentagem seria entre 40% a
50%. então eu vou ter que ligar o meu
edificador aqui no estúdio de forma que
eles fica 40%. isto aqui é muito bom
para vocês colarem na parede e assim
Vocês conseguem ver o nível de humidade
que vocês têm na divisão Se isso for um
problema para vocês Okay este aqui vou
colocar aqui no estúdio e este vai para
sala perfeito funcionamento é o que
interessa e foi barato Malta usei-me um
código assim o meu link baixem a
aplicação façam a vossa primeira compra
que tem 50% desconto vamos embora
Isto é o suporte para vocês colocarem a
gilete eu sou aquele tipo de homem que
deixa as ler à toa na casa de banho
espalhada inclusive em cima de bolos
Então isto aqui é só colar a parede e
coloca a minha gilete aqui tá tudo bem
resolvem o problema perfeito mano
olha já vem as luzes de Fora Malta
dentro desta embalagem veio luvas uma
embalagem é poque se há uma embalagem da
epóxi B
e tudo um kit de pipetas vem com
pauzinhos resina epóxi é aquela famosa
resina com o pessoal até faz tipos
culturas faz moldes faz meses e tudo
mais fica muito duro mesmo é bom para
trabalhos manuais e vamos fazer uma
experiência com esta epóxi fiquem aí
para ver mal dos próximos vídeos tudo 5
estrelas Malta e é isso malta Espero que
tenham gostado fiquem bem e até a
próxima